foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar how is
the state and sea measurement
contributes to Health Care equity
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by binding site
to learn more please visit
bindingsite.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
our speaker will answer any questions
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Gabriella lockos
Global VP medical and scientific affairs
Dr lockos you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction and thank
you all for taking time out of your busy
day and joining me to learn about this
studying C
I am very excited about this opportunity
to talk about how to improve patient
care and promote Healthcare Equity by
using this important biomarker
my name is Gabriel logoz I am vice
president of medical and scientific
Affairs a dividing site a global
individual diagnostic company
our mission is to improve patient lives
worldwide through education
collaboration and innovation
this webinar is supported my company
dividing site
the goal of this talk to describe and
Define Kidney Health inequity
also to interpret the recent
recommendations of the National Kidney
Foundation American Society of
nephrology task force for the assessment
of glomerular filtration rate
and also to discuss the advantages and
challenges of the implementation of this
pregnancy in routine laboratory use
so what is Kidney Health inequity
they say a picture is worth a thousand
words and these charts speak for
themselves
about 13 percent of the population in
the United States is black
however among those and dialysis
treatment the prevalence of blacks is
almost three-fold 35 percent
Kidney Health inequity means
disproportionate prevalence of chronic
kidney disease and dialysis treatment
as well as the risk factors for kidney
disease such as diabetes and
hypertension in black and
African-American populations
it also means lower access to Nephrology
care home dialysis treatment and kidney
transplantation
that is mounting evidence for the link
between unequal resources and
opportunities and poor Kidney Health
chronic kidney disease is defined as an
estimated glomerular filtration rate of
less than 60 milliliters per minute per
body surface area
or a urine to abdomen creatinine ratio
of greater than 30 milligrams per gram
present for three or more months
chronic kidney disease is prevalent it
is estimated that more than one in
southern adults in the United States
which is 14 of the population or 37
million people have chronic kidney
disease
nearly 800 000 of those have end-stage
kidney disease or kidney failure most of
them are on dialysis and about one-third
of them lives with a kidney transplant
the financial burden of chronic kidney
disease was estimated to be 70 billion
dollars in 2018.
and it is predicted to rise further due
to the demographic clinical and
lifestyle changes in the population
as chronic kidney disease is very
prevalent chances are that you know
several people who have chronic kidney
disease
however also chances are that they don't
know about it
it is estimated that about 90 percent of
people who have the disease are actually
not aware that they have the condition
the most important risk factors for
chronic kidney disease are diabetes and
hypertension
nearly one-third of patients with
diabetes have chronic kidney disease
although the incidence of end-stage
kidney disease in patients with diabetes
is decreasing
the prevalence of diabetes itself is
increasing more rapidly and it is
outpacing the decrease
this is a major factor to the prediction
that the prevalence of end-stage kidney
disease will increase significantly in
the next decade
chronic kidney disease is associated
with increased morbidity and mortality
mostly adverse cardiovascular outcome
such as hypertension coronary artery
disease or heart failure
they are only approximately 40 percent
of those who are at risk because they
have diabetes and less than 10 percent
of those who are at risk because of
hypertension are tested annually by both
gf5 and urine argument to creatinine
ratio as recommended by the guidelines
as I mentioned earlier chronic kidney
disease is defined by glomerular
filtration rate
and by urine to albumin urine abdomen to
creatinine ratio
GFR is estimated hence the name egfr or
estimated GFR by measuring serum
creatinine and serum since that in C and
using various equations that utilize
either creatinine only or since that in
C or both
the urine argument to creatinine ratio
is calculated from albumin and
creatinine concentration measured in a
sparkling sample
I would like to point out that other
urine tests like urine total protein
protein to creatinine Ratio or hip
securing protein tests are useful in
kidney disease screening but they are
not diagnosed with that
The Matrix on this slide shows the
stages of chronic kidney disease either
by glomerular filtration rate from G1 to
G5
or by urine argument creatinine ratio
from A1 to A3
this Matrix also clearly illustrates why
it is important to measure both GFI and
urine argument to creatinine ratio
patients may have kidney damage and
significant albumin urea even if their
egfr is above the 60 milliliter per
minute threshold
let's take a look at the measurements
that are used to estimate glomerular
filtration rate
creatinine is the most frequently used
one
it is the breakdown product of creatine
phosphate from muscle and protein
metabolism
for this reason it shows correlation
with age sex muscle mass and diet
creatinine is removed from the body by
glomerular filtration and if the
filtration rate in the kidney is
impaired we don't creatinine
concentration will rise
however creatinine is one of those
measurements with low index of
individuality which means that the
reading subject biological variation is
much smaller than the between subject
biological variation
as a result population based reference
intervals have limited clinical utility
and a normal serum creatinine
can actually hide kidney disease
there is an inverse and non-linear
relationship between serum creatinine
and glomerular filtration rate
the serum creatinine can rise and still
stay within the reference range and
therefore can hide a height a declining
glomerular filtration rate
the example on this slide shows a 65
year old woman with a serum creatinine
of 1.1 milligram per deciliter
which is within the reference interval
when we calculate each egfr taking into
account the age and sex it turns out to
be 56. which is below the 60 milliliters
per minute casual
creatinine is used in several egfr
equations some of those are shown on
this slide
the first one was the cockroached gold
equation which was created somewhat
limited amount of data in addition to
serum creatinine it included age sex and
body weight in the equation
it was mostly replaced by other
equations the two most frequently used
ones being the mdrd
modification of diet and renal disease
and the CKD Abby chronic kidney disease
epidemiological operation equation
both include age sex and race in the
calculation
so let's go back to this figure
illustrating Kidney Health inequity and
examine the relationship with estimated
GFR
equations that use raised in addition to
patients age sex and serum creatinine
they bought higher egfr for individuals
who identify as blacks as compared with
non-black individuals with the same
characteristics
this has been linked to disparities in
care including delays for the diagnosis
of kidney disease and eligibility for
kidney transplantation
what is race what is the difference
between race ethnicity and genetic
ancestry
this is someone's identification with a
group or ascribed by others on the basis
of physical characteristics such as skin
color or hair color
social contract
and it may not and actually does not
correlate with the diverse genetic
ancestry of the communities
ethnicity means set culture and language
it reflects common values cultural norms
and behaviors it is also a social
contract
genetic ancestry is an objective
biological information that estimates
the geographic origin of a person's
ancestors
it is however not available when the
glomerular filtration rate is assessed
inclusion of race in GFR equations
really ignores the diversity both within
and among racial groups and may
contribute to systemic racism in
medicine
increasing concerns about the harmful
effects of inclusion of race in GFR
equations
the National Kidney Foundation and
American Society of nephrology
established the task force in 20 2020
with the call to reassess the inclusion
of race in the estimation of GFR in the
U.S population
and also its implication for diagnosis
and management of patients
the task force has done an excellent job
and they have evaluated 26 different
equations based on six attributes
these were the availability and
standardization of the filtration essay
the feasibility and challenges of
implementation
the diversity of the population that was
included in the development of the
equation
the performance of the equation can
compare to the measure GFR which is
considered a core standard
the potential clinical population health
and research consequences and finally
patient-centeredness
they have published the outcome in two
parallel papers in the Journal of
American society of Mythology and in the
American Journal of kidney diseases
they had made three recommendations
first they recommended the immediate
implementation in all Laboratories in
the United States a new version of the
CKD epic creatinine equation without the
race variable
because this new iteration included
diversity in its development
it is immediately available has
acceptable performance characteristics
and it does not disproportionately
affect any group of individuals
they have also recommended National
effort to facilitate the increased
routine and timely use of the starting
speed especially to confront egfr in
clinical decision making
last but not least they have encouraged
research on GFR estimation and on
Intervention to eliminate racial and
ethnic disparities
this slide illustrates the potential
impact of the new equation
based on the previous CKD at the
equation a 45 year old male with a serum
creatinine of 1.45 if he identified as
black would have an egfr of 67. if he
identified as non-black would have an
egfr 58.
based on the new equation the estimated
glomerular filtration rate is 61.
in addition to eliminating the race
variable from GFR estimation
implementation of the new equation will
also have standardizing how egfr is
reported
the previously recommended and most
frequently used option was showing both
settings if African-American egfr equals
67 if not African-American egfr equals
58.
some Labs has been conscious and
concerned about the race variable and
have chosen to report it as a range
58-67
others simply omitted the race variable
and reported only one number number as
if everybody was non-black
this however could lead to significant
inaccuracies and is not recommended
the new equation has only one output
ejfr equals 61 and this simplifies and
standardizes Reporting
overall it is expected that the
prevalence of chronic kidney disease in
black society increase and in
non-blacked persons they slightly
decreased as a result of the new
calculation
let's examine the performance
characteristics of the new egfr
creatinine equation
on each of these charts there are so
thousands of data points each data point
represents the patient
the horizontal axis shows the estimated
GFI and the vertical axis shows the
measured GFR which is considered a gold
standard the reference value
black line represents the line of
identity
the green line is the curve fitted on
the black population
and the orange line is the fur fitted on
the non-black population
there are three numbers that you need to
pay attention to
the first one is the bias
it is the median difference between the
measured and estimated glomerular
circulation rate
if it is a positive number the
glomerular filtration rate is
underestimated if it is a negative
number the GFR is overestimated
the other parameter is P30 which
represents accuracy it is the percentage
of patients whose estimated GFR fall
within 30 percent of the measured GFR
30 is considered acceptable error limit
for egfr
finally Decora classification refers to
chronic kidney disease stages from J1 to
G5 and it shows the percentage of
patients who fall in the same category
based on estimated GFR and measured GFI
the left panel shows the performance of
the current equation and the right panel
shows the performance of the new 2021
equation without the risk variable
with the current equation all three
parameters I mentioned bias accuracy and
quora classification so verse
performance in the black population
compared to non-blacks
the new equation has corrected the
overestimation of GFR in the black
population
and increase the accuracy from 85 to 87
percent
as a result the performance of the new
equation is balanced between black and
non-black participants
so what about other equations using
system C or the combination of
creatinine and systems
the starting C is a 13 kilodalton basic
protein that is produced by all
nucleated cells and it is freely
filtered by the glomeruli which makes it
the perfect glomerular filtration marker
it appears to be less affected by age
sex muscle mass diet and raised and
creatinine
it is measured by in the United States
and the values are traceable to the ifcc
reference material
as I have mentioned earlier the second
recommendation of the National Kidney
Foundation American Society of astrology
task force was to facilitate the
increased routine and timely use of the
statistics especially as a confirmation
test and to support better clinical
decision making
so let's take a look at the egfr
cystalgency equation
this graph is similar to the previous
one
the horizontal axis shows the estimated
GFR the vertical axis shows the measure
gf5 the black line is the line of
identity the green line is the first
fitted on the blood population and the
orange line is
the curve fitted on the non-gov
population
looking at the performance
characteristics this equation is
remarkably accurate it has very low bias
in both black and non-black and it has a
relatively high accuracy rate
this equation actually does not include
the race variable in the computation and
therefore no receipt was needed
it also has minimal differential buyer
differential bias is actually the
difference between the bias in the black
and non deck population
in this case it is only 0.8 milliliters
per minute
as opposed to the system equation the
equation that uses both creatinine and
cystatin C did undergo a repeat because
it included rays in the calculation
the current equation shown on the left
was very accurate to begin with
however it had the same issue as the
creatinine equation
it overestimated vulnerable filtration
in Black participants
the new equation showed on the right
hand side corrected this bias and
increased the accuracy from 89 to 91
percent in Black
this 2021 creatinine starting equation
is that currently available most
accurate equation it also has small
differential bias
the results that I have shown clearly
demonstrate the critical usefulness of
the statistic measurement and also that
the most accurate GFR estimation
includes both serum creatinine and
system
measurement should be considered as
confirmatory tasks in situations when
egfr based on serum creatinine is
suspected to be inaccurate
some of these conditions are listed on
this slide for example extreme body size
video and malnutrition or obesity muscle
diseases or vegetarian diet
it is also recommended in clinical
situations when a very accurate GFR
value is needed for example for dosing
of chemotherapy drugs or antibiotics
that are cleared by the kidney
or for kidney donation evaluation
the certainty measurement is also
recommended to confirm chronic kidney
disease stage g3a
when the GFR is between 45 and 59 and
there are no other markers of kidney
damage
and also to confirm that lack of chronic
kidney disease in patients who have an
estimated GFR of 60 to 74.
we have to acknowledge though that there
are significant barriers for the
adoption of cystatency in rooting
clinical practice
based on the 2019 College of American
pathology survey only two percent of
Laboratories offered system CSA and 90
has sent it out
the situation has likely changed since
2019 but these data suggests that
cystadency is not offered by the
majority of clinical chemistry labs
which has an impact on both costs and
turnaround time
the starting thing is also more
expensive more than three times more
expensive than creatinine and require
special instrumentation because it is
measured by immune essay
restrictive insurance coverage further
limits the widespread availability of
the starting fee and should be the focus
of concerted efforts from Healthcare
patient organizations and the industry
in the last part of my talk I'm going to
show some examples for the clinical
usefulness to study and the studying C
based GFR calculation
in one of the recent meta-analysis shown
on the left side the authors compare the
performance of seven different statisty
and creatinine base equations from 26
studies or the prediction of Vancomycin
clearance
creatinine based equations demonstrated
a statistically significant positive
bias
27.6 milliliter per minute
why are cystating speed based
calculations are unbiased and accurate
in another meta-analysis
shown on the right hand side
authors analyzed 14 studies comparing
system C and creatinine clearance for
the prediction of the elimination of
multiple drugs
they have extended the correlation
between renal function as I said by
either creatinine or assisted in c-base
equations and the clearance of linearly
excreted drugs
13 out of the 14 studies showed that the
starting civil Superior to creatinine to
predict the elimination of the evaluated
dog
another study looked at the performance
of serum system
creatinine in critical ill patients in
the Intensive Care Unit in comparison
with measured GFR to predict a decreased
glomerular filtration rate
based on Rock curve analysis they don't
see statins they clearly outperformed
serum creatinine for the prediction of
the GFR threshold of 60 milliliters per
minute
the area under the curve was the
starting state was significantly larger
than for creatinine
the starting speed base egfr equations
have also been evaluated in multiple
myeloma
one study compared the performance of
multiple in GFR equations in newly
diagnosed multiple myeloma including the
mdrd
the CKD epic creatinine the starting C
and creatinine system equation
this study found that the starting seed
based equations identified higher number
of multiple myeloma patients with renal
impairment
28.6 percent of patients were
reclassified into higher security stages
according to the system C equation
compared to the mdrd formula
in addition the starting c-base GFR
independently predicted survival
if you take a look at the details we can
see that actually all equations produce
similar median overall survival
prediction for patients with stage one
or two chronic kidney disease
however the starting base equations
shown in the lower panel demonstrated a
significant difference in overall
survival for patients with chronic
kidney disease stage 3 and 5.
sorry three to five
you can see how the survival occurs
separate from each other on the two
lower graphs showing the performance of
the CKD at the system
and the CKD epic creatinine system
equation
as a conclusion authors have suggested
that through the measurement of system C
could be incorporated in the workup of
newly diagnosed multiple myeloma
and also suggested that the equations
using the starting C should replace the
ndrd formula in this patient group
in another study the starting sea base
estimated GFI was a better predictor of
Adverse Events in the elderly including
mortality heart failure bone loss
peripheral artery disease and cognitive
impairment compared to creatinine based
estimated GFI
this graph shows Hazard ratios for that
from any cause
according to whether egfr was calculated
with the measurement of creatinine or
system C or both
the hazard ratios were adjusted for age
sex space body mass and other variables
describe illustrates that egfr based on
cystatin C and so in red
outperforms egfr based on creatinine and
even the combination of creatinine and
cystatency
to start and see essays are available as
automated in the United States from many
commercial sources and on many different
platforms the tests are standardized and
the values are traceable to the ifcc
reference material
although some differences between
different brands have been reported in
the literature
this quite commercial availability will
hopefully facilitate the sustained
adoption of cystatency measurement
including clinical lab
in conclusion the use of the risk
coefficient in GFR estimating equations
is problematic and no longer recommended
the National Kidney Foundation American
Society of nephrology task force
recommend the immediate implementation
of the CKD epic creatinine equation
receipts without the race variable in
all Laboratories
the task force recommend the increased
routine and timely use of cystatency
especially to confirm egfr in patients
who are at risk for or who have chronic
kidney disease
the second C is a glomerular filtration
marker that is less affected by age sex
muscle mass diet and race than
creatinine
the CKD episode equation does not
include raising the calculation
the combination of creatinine insisted
in C provides more accurate GFR
estimation that either marker alone
and that is emerging evidence for the
superior performance of egfr using
system measurements in critical ill
patients
for dosing renal excreted drugs
as predictor of Adverse Events in
elderly and for predicting survival in
patients with multiple myeloma
I hope you find the information I have
presented helpful and you will make
efforts to implement system measurement
in your own Laboratory
thank you very much for your attention
please feel free to submit questions and
I will be answering those by email